I mean animated could be fun I I swear
to God I brought that up to Al at the
crater of Smaug I said we should do an
animated Smallville because they're
doing comic books
I'm just missing him this weekend I
guess the series continues and all the
guests are the plate certain guest stars
bring them in dialogue Michael you've
worked with one of my idols Andre Romano
doing the flash yeah know who that is
retired I heard of the flash yeah she's
you do the voice hey everybody it's
Charlie so we got to talk about Flash
Smallville crossover now that they're
joking about actually doing an animated
series it sounds like it might become a
thing in the future there's always
potential because that DC streaming
service is starred for content they're
developing so many new shows for that so
I'll try to explain you know what the
easiest way to accomplish this is and
what the actual potential for it is
because it sounds like Michael Rosenbaum
is a little more hungry for stuff like
this to happen than Tom Welling who is
actually sort of dipping his toe back in
the fandom waters so if you are finding
me for the first time be sure to
subscribe to get all the videos so just
address this footage first this is them
at awesome con doing a Smallville panel
I'm just really happy that Tom Welling
is doing conventions in general most of
the actors do a lot of conventions but
Tom Welling was one of the holdouts
because he said during the Smallville
era when that was on the air the network
wasn't really hot on the actors doing
the convention circuit but now they're
totally cool with it so we'll probably
see more Tom Welling doing Superman
panels as he goes around and does
whatever other projects after he's done
with Lucifer but if he didn't see it a
little while ago I did a flash
Smallville what if crossover video like
you know how would they accomplish this
there's just some very easy ways that
you could use the powers that
people have liked Cisco and Barry to
meet people from other Earth's for the
most part in the comics the flash is the
path to the multiverse because he can
phase through different dimensions but
one of the biggest holdups is getting
the actors to agree to it like do they
actually want to come back into this
universe and play a version of their
character or a different character and
to getting different production studios
to agree to it because even though
Smallville was a CW show I mean it
started WB err like it was a bunch of
regime changes while Smallville was
happening because it was early CW era is
that the people that make the air /
shows the Berlanti verse don't own
Smallville they didn't do that show so
it's a completely different group of
producers that are involved that you
have to get on board for something like
that like if you're gonna do more
Smallville characters usually you have
to get there okay even though you also
have to get the okay of the network so
full-blown Smallville crossover just has
to jump over a couple hurdles but it's a
lot easier to do in the animated
universe and what have they just done
the last couple of years in the
arrowverse they've done those short
animated projects they just did vixen
season two they just dropped a brand new
Constantine series a couple weeks ago it
would actually be pretty easy for them
to do a narrow verse crossover with the
Smallville characters in the animated
universe if they actually wanted to do a
full-blown animated revival series they
could do that on the streaming service
that really would require the other
producers the Berlanti verse people
probably couldn't take part in that
they're already a couple different
streaming shows that are gonna be on
that DC service you have Titans they're
gonna have a show from the gotham people
called metropolis you can imagine the
direction they're gonna take with that
it's gonna focus mostly on lex luthor
and lois lane a whole bunch of other
animated projects from Warner Brothers
animation like Young Justice season 3
the Harley Quinn show most of all those
different shows are from different
people it's not like one person greg
berlanti doing all the arrowverse shows
on the CW it gets way more complicated
when you have all those cooks in the
kitchen but not impossible if they can
do a crossover with scooby-doo and
supernatural they can for sure do the
same thing with the arrowverse and the
Smallville characters I think it's just
a question of timing availability and
getting the network to approve something
like that because somebody's got to pay
for it they have to
whether or not they're gonna make a
return on it I think fans would be down
for anything them revisiting these
characters would be a lot of fun even if
it's only something that's really brief
but here's a couple more funny clips of
them just talking about crazy stuff that
happened on the show as a series
progress we would both do we'd have
nonverbal gestures like if one of our
take was just we trusted each other
I'd go Clark how many times have I told
you you can trust me and keep looking or
he give me a wake like that means you
suck dude again hey guys I wanted to
talk a little bit about the finale and
Michael thank you for coming back for
that I think that was something we were
all waiting for that was cool yeah
there's a Ritz our real quick that was a
big thing because he didn't have to that
was very much Michael it was it was
really strange though because we showed
up the set and he hadn't been there a
few years and we're like what are you
doing and he's like it's for now now
where's where's my lines I feel weird am
I doing this right am i but we did it we
you helped me get back into it I
remember the first take you remember the
giant crane in the Luthor mansion it's
just all it's all destroyed that comes
down on me to open it and I go
and I got rose and bombs back I think
one of the worst things we did was well
not that we did on the show but watching
you be Zod flying through the air that
was probably one of the worst things why
do you have to bring up all these things
it was like therapy for me I'm bringing
it up bro they brought him my wires one
day outside he come to lose I wearing it
they made it for me he's very unbalanced
he had to say very sort of on these
wires like 40 feet and also you guys
about 10 feet off the air and his body
just starts to turn like this well the
wrong way well it's strange when you're
playing these characters where then they
show these alter egos of these gear and
what was my first line when I landed how
do we know you laughs that we take we
almost didn't get the scene finally
kneel to Zod like you look like such an
idiot I love hearing them talk about how
ridiculous they got behind the scenes I
hope we get to the point where Stephen
Amell in the arrowverse actors can do
stuff like that - speaking of which they
actually tease the big cliffhanger
that's gonna happen at the end of arrow
this season
Sarah is coming back for the finale so
they obviously be some birds of prey
earth to Laurel stuff happening they'll
try and wrap up that arc but the
craziest thing they could do in my mind
to refresh the show and go out and like
on a really big note would be to have
Oliver actually leave Star City at some
point during the season because for the
most part is a mayor of a city you don't
have an indefinite term like there is a
ticking clock eventually you're not
going to be mayor so like Smallville you
spend a bunch of seasons on that
show but most of the time the last
couple of seasons you're traveling
around like Smallville eventually
transitioned to metropolis the last
couple of seasons they could always do
the same thing with arrow where they go
to a different city but what'll happen
is is I'll post my arrow episode video
tomorrow the flash is back next week so
they'll be some more flash posting in
the next couple of days leave all your
DC video requests in the comments below
click here for my flash season 5 video
and click here for brand new Titans
season 1 thank you so much for watching
everybody stay awesome I'll see you guys
tonight